So what is an editable property? So on the door locked what you'll see is a
little eye
Icon, although you can't see when it's closed
You can definitely see when it opens so I'm going to click it and it's opened an eye
So that's a shut eye with a little eyelash. That's an open eye. So I want to open the eye
I'm gonna click compile and save I'm gonna go back into my map and when I select the door
You'll see now we've got door properties here, which says is locked
It means we can edit this is locked property on the fly and because I called it door properties
Because I had good naming convention that door properties in this category again
You don't need to do this, but whatever you called this category. You can now see that as a category
keeps things nice and organized in your level and
You'll be able to see that the door is locked now
the really powerful thing here is if I duplicate this door, I'm gonna hold down alt and left click and
Drag out again, you could have added it as well by hitting ctrl and spacebar
we go to our quick draw and you can add it as a
Door in the level, but I don't want to add these doors
If you if you just select the door that you duplicated and you say is locked
No, so this store on the right that's locked. That's not going to open. This store is not locked
No click so when I play this I would expect the first door not to open so I'm pressing e
Tapping e on my keyboard if I start that print string saying is locked that would not be opening
So that's worked if I go over to here and pressing now the door opens
So that's a very very quick way to say is door locked
Yes, or no, and then I've got two different instances. And again, I've not had to edit any code apart from a tick box here
So that's a really powerful functionality of
exposing
Variables so that they're editable inside of a blueprint and you can have loads of good customization here
You can set light colors. You could add
times for things to animate over, you know, the
creativity gets involved at that point and what kind of quick editable customization you want for your blueprints and
What you could add in order to save time?